[Musique]
organisé par le Conseil général dans le
cadre des célébrations du peuplement de
la Réunion le projet Carné de voyage a
pour but de recueillir les écrits de
collégiens réunonnais parti à la
découverte des différents pays dont ils
sont
originaires la classe 403 du collège le
compte de lî s'envole pour Madagascar
lors de leur voyage qui a pour
thématique le savoirfaire les élèves
mèneront des actions solidaires au
centre d'hébergement à à
vou j'espère justement que ce projet va
encore développer cette solidarité
qu'ils ont pu mettre en œuvre auprès des
personnes âgées de la maison de retraite
par exemple et de les ouvrir sur le
monde mais un monde qui est à la fois
proche de chez eux dont certains sont
originaires parce qu'à Saint-Louis il y
a des origines malgaches encore assez
présentes et et en fait un monde aussi
complètement différent du leur le jour
du départ est enfin arrivé après
desevoir rapide mais plein d'émotion ce
sont des élèves motivés par l'aventure
qui arrivent à l'aéroport ils
transportent avec eux par moins de 350
kg de carton pour les enfants du
centre Etel livre ses impressions sur
ses au revoir à ses parents au début c
un peu difficile mais après quand on
pense que on va faire ça pendant une
semaine dem ça il faut dire que la
plupart d'entre eux voyage seul et quit
le cocon familial pour la première fois
l'appréhension se fait sentir mais la
l'aventure vite oublier le stress du
tret la classe arrive sous le soleil
d'Iv direction bam au lieu d'hébergement
pour déposer les bagages selon la taille
de la valise on se débrouille comme on
peut la riche de la Faun et de la flore
de madas
réun au parc zoologique et au lur par
c'est le long des allé boisé que les
découvertes se
[Musique]
poursuivent les sorties sont aussi
l'occasion d'en apprendre un peu plus
sur le savoir-faire et le mode de vie
malge avec patience et humilité les
élèves découvrent la force et Laé des
habitants de l'écovillage de
Tsaratanana certains visages semblent
familiers les origines communes se
remarquent ici les jeunes réunionnés
prennent conscience que la réalité du
quotidien des Malgaches n'est pas la
même que chez
eux la dextérité des artisans de
l'atelier de maquette de bateau éville
la curiosité de la
classe à l'extérieur la tranquillité du
jardin tropical invite les voyageurs
fatigués au
repos mais la motivation reprend
rapidement le dessus à amboujaam les
rignonnais découvrent les vestiges du
rouva et de ses
tombeaux découverte d'antananaarve de la
beauté de ses risières de sa population
et surtout sa
circulation sur les hauteurs le palais
de la reine accueille les visiteurs en
tout genre
des Michell de retour sur sa terre
natale profite du spectacle pour se
ressourcer au fameux marché de la dig
les techniques de négociation sont vite
assimilé par ses acheteurs
en la journée se termine en beauté sur
le point de vue incroyable de la colline
bleue
la pluie rythme les soirées à Madagascar
les filles en profitent pour
retranscrire leur aventure dans les
carnets de voyage qu'elles ont ell même
fabriqué
alors on a trpé du papier fin avec on a
trempé dans l'eau et après on a bien
écasé on attrapé un cadre on a mis du
tissu fin et a on a mis du papier dedans
et après quand c'est bien sec et ben on
a OBU des
feuilles au centre avou que l'accueil
est chaleureux les sourir et
l'impatience des 151 enfants et de la
bienveillante directrice Madame
lalaanina submerge les collégiens et
leur professeurs dès leur
arrivé à canev c'est un centre d'accueil
des enfants abandonnés
ou maltraités ou des enfants qui ont
subi de de de
violence les premiers contacts se font
avec un peu de réserve puis la
discussion se fait de plus en plus
facilement malgré la barrière de la
langue enfin les proméens se tissent
tout naturellement autour du rire et de
l'amusement les réionnis prennent
conscience des difficultés de certains
enfants de la grande île et s'attaquent
au grand déballage des cartons qui avec
un peu d'organisation se met rapidement
en
place la journée verte est un événement
très symbolique à dans la continé du
projet d'autonomie alimentaire du centre
la classe aide à planter de beaux arbres
fruitiers pour planter des arbres comme
ça pour pour les fruits et pour le
centre divisé en petits groupes enfants
et adultes s'attaquent à la tâche ardu
du nettoyage des parcelles conscient de
l'importance de leur
action Xavier et waa trouvent un peu de
réconfort auprès de leur famille pas
question malgré le manque de laisser la
tristesse prendre le dessus oui allô
Alloui bonjour c'est la gendarmerie de
Saint-Louis on vous appelle parce
[Musique]
quean c'est
moi bon tout se passe bien ça va maman
là raccroche fais un bisou papa oui
bisous à plus allez
allez au centre
jordanovan coup de
ag pour les filles atelier bijoux elles
deviennent professeur pour les enfants
du centre et transmettent à leur tour
leur
savoir-faire au dortoir des garçons
c'est peinture pour tous peu importe la
technique les élèves privilégiés
apprennent la technique unique de
fabrication de charbon de Monsieur André
impressionné il réalise qu'ici avec peu
il est possible de faire
beaucoup passage par le lavoir où Ismaël
explique à loï les techniques age
à loin des parents l'entraide se fait
d'elle-même entre les
collégiens pour CHR c'est le moment
idéal pour réfléchir à la réalité des
enfants du centre moi je trouve
que on a les parents et tout mais les
enfants du centre n'ont pas de parents
donc il faut essayer de d'apporter le
maximum d'amour
pour cacher
cette
tristesse
les réunionnés ont pris leur marques sur
cette terre d'accueil qui leur semble
maintenant familière mais pas le temps
de s'attarder car aujourd'hui c'est le
jour de la velum parti fête d' revoir à
Akou à peine arrivé tous se retrouent et
profit des derniers instants l'émotion
est déjà
forte côté cuisine ce sont les
réunionnés qui sont en charge du repas
pour près de 185 personnes et cela
demande une certaine
organisation en profite pour faire le
bilan sur son aventure que le voyage de
il Sonis à la pauvreté et aux gens qui
n'ont pas de toit et et les gens que qui
vient dans la rue si comme nous on a
tout à la ré et n
rien certains collégiens sont habillés
coifé en tenue traditionnelle c'est une
belle occasion pour en apprendre
davantage sur la culture de ce
pays
avant de démarrer les festivités photos
de groupe avec l'ensemble des enfants
réunir autant de personnes n'est pas une
mince affaire mais le clicher est
mémorable c'est en rythme que l'on
célèbre le voyage et les moments passés
[Musique]
ensemble puis il est temps de se dire au
revoir les cœurs sont lourds mais la de
partie de la famille d'akani avou prend
le dessus sur la
tristesse waa venu à la recherche de ses
origines fait le point sur son
séjour on a on a eu des moments de pleur
de joie euh des moments où comment ça on
se bataille aussi ensemble et tout mais
à la fin ben on est comme une grande
famille on est venu ici on a passé une
très belle aventure et ben maintenant
c'est la fin comme toute chose a une fin
ce sont des parents impatients qui
attendent leurs enfants partis du cocon
familial depuis 11 jours et revenu
grandi
etchanger en fait bon c'est mon je suis
content qu' y aller pour découvrir
beaucoup de choses là-bas en fait a
jamais voyagé tout seul c'est la
première fois bon ça fait du bien
quoi retour au collège là où tout a
commencé le bilan se fait mais le
contact est gardé et certains espèrent
pouvoir un jour retourner à Madagascar
les actions continuent pour cette classe
marqué à jamais par ce
voyage VI
[Applaudissements]
va